il était 16 heures ce dimanche quand les
bureaux de vote béninois ont fermé alors
que le dépouillement des bulletins est
encore en cours le pays attend de savoir
qui arrivera en tête du scrutin
présidentiel
mais la surprise n'est vraiment pas de
mise président sortant face à seulement
deux candidats
patrice talon est le grand favori à sa
propre succession et les sondages
l'annoncent même gagnant dès le premier
tour
une victoire quasiment assurée même si
l'opposition ne perd pas espoir
j'essaierai au pouvoir dans les jours ou
les heures qui suivent je pense que je
verrais bien à ce que la paix règne dans
le pays
patrice talon est allé voter ce dimanche
matin à cotonou un geste pas vraiment
imité par l'ensemble des béninois dans
certains bureaux de vote de la capitale
les taux de participation n'était que de
30 % il faut dire que l'élection attire
peu en cause l'appel au boycott du
scrutin par les grandes figures de
l'opposition mais aussi un contexte
électrique avec de nombreuses violences
entre population et forces de l'ordre
les échauffourées dure depuis plusieurs
mois dans le pays et ont fait plusieurs
morts et blessés
une réponse musclée de l'exécutif pointé
du doigt alors que le président sortant
met en cause l'opposition
il fait des espoirs que
aujourd'hui encore ce sera un jour à la
fin on constatera que les intimidations
la peur ne pas savoir grand chose
je crois que la force de votre sécurité
obligé de l'association regardez le cam
qu'il faut sept enfants qui ont été
manipulés c'est le jeune de tribulations
être maîtrisé avait peur beaucoup de
compétences respectives malgré les
tensions le premier tour s'est déroulé
sans incident majeur
le pays devrait être fixé ce lundi ou
demain en cas de victoire patrice talon
effectuera un second mandat de cinq ans
à la tête du bénin